but where I do draw my inspiration is
from whatever I can glean about the
nature of the world you know Buddha was
a person who confronted reality actually
according to our understanding of what
Buddha was he was not a prophet who was
commissioned by a God to go out and
proclaim that everybody should believe
in that God so that they then to because
that God can then save them but I talked
to the gods and the God said look we
can't really help we are very powerful
and we help some people in some ways but
we can't change people's evolutionary
destiny it's up to them and so Buddha
taught people that they if they confront
themselves and reality they can
understand themselves and reality and
when they do they will be inspired they
will be cheered up because reality
itself is a source of nourishment it's a
source of health it's a source of joy if
you really know it they're all the
misery and all the incite
unsatisfactoriness and all the
dissatisfaction comes from being caught
in different kinds of illusions and
trying to manipulate the world to sort
of fit with whatever your illusion is
and fit it into your illusion and then
of course the world doesn't react too
well and you can't do that and so then
you get sick or you die or you suffer
and then you you always frustrated so my
inspiration actually comes from I don't
and I don't claim to be enlightened but
I have had a little better exposure to
reality by developing a little bit more
sharp critical mindedness and focused
mindedness and and by doing that I see
the world I think more realistically
than I did and by seeing it that way I
get inspired and by a bee and I get
cheered up and then by being inspired to
cheer up I'd like to see other people
inspired and cheered up but the problem
is you can't just inspire them and cheer
them up by telling them to believe in
something like a religious thing you
have to encourage them and that's why
teaching is a great privilege and a
wonderful thing to do because by
teaching you can in the true sense that
which doesn't mean indoctrinating and it
doesn't mean sort of brainwashing and
this sort of thing truly teaching means
bringing out people's own intelligence
and letting them suddenly feel their own
critical mind that they can see through
the delusions that
boy stood upon them by their culture and
bye-bye you know the media and all sorts
of things and that is a real thrill when
someone said wow you know understand
something new and has like it profound
either its aesthetic or philosophical
experience and it's it's a real joy to
see that happen in someone really oh so
so that's what that's where my
inspiration comes from is trying to be
more aware of reality really ignorant we
know too foolish people say ignorance is
bliss but it's the opposite
ignorance is suffering and wisdom is
bliss you know meaning realistic
knowledge of the world